[Musik]
jetzt geht es nur noch darum dass ich
mich würdig verabschiedet ich hatte
einige zeiten kein geld nichts geerbt
also hast du nicht gehabt muss es auch
noch deine eltern unterstützen
nein man muss dennoch unterschreiben
dass er damit einverstanden ist dafür
berufstätig ist da war ich dann also als
frau wie erste die so finanzen wird
gemacht hat
und wenn nicht an 2,7 millionen sehe
dann weiß ich du hast das alles richtig
gemacht
ich geld als frauen vorbild als
inspiration
das ist dem geldanlage krisen und crash
und kolumbien buch und da habe ich dir
auch nette widmung krankgeschrieben so
für alle zeiten da habe ich wirklich
zwei jahre lang bild kolumne geschrieben
ich wusste dass krebs habe aber in
dieser abscheulichkeit habe ich ja auch
nicht erwartet